so we're talking about
money money money money money we're
talking about capital we're talking
about money leading to
control uh on a geopolitical
stage so
is there any merit to what is happening
in the south china sea
do we need to be worried about taiwan
semiconductor about taiwan
about what is happening in
china's military and where we're
eventually going with this is he who
rules the sea
and the whole idea of reserve currency
status
because in the history of mankind going
back to the roman empire
it's never been lost if there's just
been
a currency war or if a currency war has
escalated to a trade war
it's only if you get to that third step
where it escalates to a hot war
that the currency itself is at play
and at risk and but as you just said
less than two percent of global
transactions are being done
however they're looking for a workaround
so i'm i'm curious
if it is just saber rattling or if it's
something that
the world needs to be paying closer
attention to because prior to the
current administration
there were many there there were many
times that
it was brought up before world tribunals
and
and said what china is doing is in
violation of international law and yet
nothing has been done nothing has still
been done
so um south china sea
the the chinese communist party told the
people's liberation army
back in the 70s hey the vietnamese are
starting to move into these
uh islands in the south china sea we
need to do something about it and pla
told the chinese communist party
we don't have the resources we don't
have aircraft carriers we don't have
that we
we can't sustain any kind of effort down
there because how are we going to fuel
our ships
how are we going to keep them
operational so so
that's in the 70s you know fast forward
to you know 2013
2014 now they finally have
you know the resources and so they start
building the islands in the south china
sea
so the whole point of the islands in the
south china sea is this is fed by the
russians
the technology military the the
in terms of the
helping build the actual aircraft
carriers themselves oh yes but i mean
the in essence the the the islands are
just basically aircraft carriers
that don't go anywhere so they so they
basically built islands
aircraft right they're stationary
aircraft carriers because they they can
they have dredgers they can
dredge up sand they can make islands the
whole point of that was it was a
long-term strategy by the people's
liberation army to answer what the
chinese communist party told them which
is
get control of the south china sea so
now they have the islands
they can they have ships down there they
have planes down there and they can
begin to coerce their neighbors and say
this
is ours the resources the fish the the
natural gas the oil
all of it is ours and those are
international commercial lanes
nobody nobody can have no they're
actually according to the chinese
there's
it's the chinese lake right they they
own it
so but this is getting to your point
about um
do i think there is a potential for a
hot wheels so
i don't think there is right now but the
risk
is increasing now the the thing that i
think
keeps the chinese at bay from the united
states
is the same thing that keeps the us at
bay with regard to
russia and that's nuclear weapons so
nobody else in the region has nuclear
weapons
so the chinese communist party feels uh
pretty
safe just going around and bullying
their neighbors because nobody has
nuclear weapons no
who is going to oppose them and so
i can expect that you're going to see
more and more of this as time goes on
as you lead into this this question
about
um is there going to be you know
is there going to be a change in the
reserve currency i don't think so
because the chinese aren't willing to
allow their currency to float and
there's no way that anybody's going to
want to take the yuan if
the only way they can exchange it is to
go begging at the people's bank of china
so i don't think that
so are we going to have a war a hot war
between
kind of the united states and china i
don't think so because of nuclear
weapons number one
number two i don't think the chinese are
going to get exchange
or reserve currency status except within
that economic sphere that i talked about
with the belt and road initiative which
is very demographically
i mean that's some of the best
demographics in the world that you
describe right
so so and this gets back to the
competition
so when i talk about to people about
what the national security strategy says
it's really about three things protect
and that's really we got to cut that
link
we got to stop that stuff flowing
rebuild okay since
innovation technology and talent's not
going to china now we're going to go
the united states other democracies
right and then inspire and this is
really where we get back to what we're
doing the cold war kind of like the
marshall plan right
we take usaid export endpoint bank
trade development agency development
finance corporation millennium challenge
corporation
we work with allies and partners and we
begin to
at the same time that we're doing
economic development very much like the
chinese are doing because they have been
very strategic
about how they develop economically but
at the same time we're doing
public diplomacy we're talking about the
values and principles that are
that go with our system and we do that
strategically
you know on the fringes of where the
chinese have
basically grabbed territory because the
third part is called inspire
you inspire the people that are behind
the curtain
by saying we have a better life for you
not only
do we have better economic growth but
you can do it in your way
right you know you're you're free to be
who you want to be right you can meet
your true potential
this is what we were doing during the
cold war we were inspiring people
it wasn't about fighting it was about
showing that we had a better system
a better system for humanity and what
happens is
as you begin to do that as because
when you brought china into the tent the
system began to fall apart and we didn't
recognize it
you know the stock market's growing
people are getting wealthy but
but we quietly learned that lesson in
the korean war others are getting
we just didn't take enough away from the
korean war
right but you know that was kind of a
microcosm of what we're talking about
here which is total systemic collapse
and and so you have to basically begin
to heal that system and as it grows up
and as you
help certain other emerging market
economies that
actually want to go a different way but
you know
if you look today in terms of what usaid
does in africa
just look at water congress gives them
water for
a certain country you know you have this
pot of money
for a water project in nigeria for
example
because i went to usaid i said what's
your strategy for development in africa
and they looked at me like what are you
talking about
what the chinese do are say identify a
resource
build the way to get that resource
identify a port connect them with
roads and rail telecommunications power
or water
now what do they do they start putting
in low value added manufacturing
urbanization to support the workers that
are that are working in the factories
now you've gotta you know you've gone
from a a
backwater to industrial economy to
information economy
fifty dollar smartphones you're using
wechat tencent alibaba
all of these companies start to this
begins now you've got an information
economy
and when we do development populist
that's beholden to you by the way
exactly and so when we you we that's
what we did
if you think about that was a marshall
plan yeah it's exactly what we did
except rather than you know
being piece meal like we've been for the
last 30 years
it was focused it was about building the
civil society
at the same time we were building a
comprehensive you know
economic capability that was tied to the
united states
this is we stopped doing that at the end
of the cold war
and at that's the same time the chinese
came in and said
okay you're not going to do that but
that's a great idea we're going to do it
we're going to tie it to our way of
looking at the world and it's worked for
them
beautifully because our business sector
and our our financial sector has
actually been
involved with them doing that that's
what mackenzie when mackenzie gave me
the report in in the white house that
says hey we should partner with africa
or with china and africa and i'm like
what are you talking about and i asked
him i said who did you interview for
this report
the business owners who are they chinese
who else
the leaders of the countries
authoritarians who else did you and did
you interview any of the people i
literally asked them that
right they said well i asked the taxi
driver here and there
so and you actually get
to kind of the the incestuous nature
of wall street and the and the
consulting firms that they deal with all
the time
but it's just it's it's affirmation bias
it's it's
you might as well be conducting really
expensive research inside of a vacuum
because that's as much value out as
you're going to get out of it sorry
um but you know a country
a country's name continues to pop into
my mind and that is india
it would seem that if there are any
global
allies that are
for lack of a better term up for grabs
that that there is a ton of focus right
now on the potential
in india that by the way has more people
in it than china and they're a lot
younger it would seem to me
that somebody in washington dc
needs to be hyper focused on building a
fantastic relationship
with a country that has always
assisted our service economy
and i have i have friends who have
entire workforces in india and
and can't speak highly enough about
their work ethic and their
adoption of of the of education
but it would seem to me that in addition
to everybody we consider to be our
traditional
if you want to go back to the cold war
the old cold war everybody who was on
our side then
plus india seems like we've got a
fighting chance plus there's a lot of
for american companies to go in and do
economically i mean when you think about
the
i'll go back to the korean war for a
minute the japanese economy was on its
heat
it was on its knees but we were
occupying it at the time
and we you know logistically speaking we
couldn't get everything we needed to
fight the korean war
so what do we do we fired up the
industrial base in
in japan and it ended up being a win-win
because japan
ended up becoming obviously one of our
great allies and japan
does not trust china to this day and
that's not a bad thing
[Music]